let me give you an example of a real
estate or a mortgage professional that
is all day long one of the most clever
moves everyone can do here attention is
the number one asset you start a podcast
around the town you do business in and
now you're reaching out to people that
you want to do business with and instead
of trying to sell to them you tell the
rich dentist in your town hey you're a
pretty amazing dentist you want to be on
my podcast to tell people about your
Dentistry now you've just turned a sales
pitch and not into a sales pitch but now
you're giving the dentist a platform now
that dude's come to your [__] house
house now you're [__] friends now you
get their [__] business that's a good
idea and by the way let me tell you
about humans they've all got egos even
though nobody's listening to your
podcast nobody asked that dentist to
ever be on a podcast before and he's
[__]
pumped